en plus du cours difficilement
maîtrisable de la pandémie
la france doit affronter un autre
problème sanitaire l'écho vide l'on est
selon l' oms ces malades aux symptômes
persistants représente de 10 à 15 % de
ceux qui ont contracté l'infection au
niveau mondial deux cent cinquante mille
à trois cent mille personnes en france
selon la haute autorité de santé il
développe des gènes et douleur longtemps
après l'infection parfois plus de six
mois leurs symptômes une fatigue intense
des gênes respiratoires des douleurs
musculaires ou articulaires des troubles
de la concentration et de la mémoire de
l'odorat et du goût des problèmes
digestifs de 50 à 100 symptômes ont déjà
été répertoriés qui sont les malades
type des personnes âgées ou encore
plutôt jeunes davantage de femmes autour
de la quarantaine sans co morbidité dans
une étude de mai dernier
ces malades représentent 60% des
patients hospitalisés pour le coc vide
en effet il existe une corrélation entre
la gravité des symptômes initiaux un
passage en réanimation et la survenance
d'un kobe de l'an dès septembre 2020 l'
oms avait repéré ces malades atteints de
symptômes persistants en pointe contre
cette forme particulière de la maladie
la grande bretagne a été très
douloureusement affecté par le cos vide
faute de mesures drastiques au départ
mais elle a su prendre soin de ses co
vie de long qui sautent au nombre d'un
million actuellement
grâce à une application recensant des
mars 2020 les effets du co vide
elle a pu disposer d'informations pour
comprendre ces malades très particulier
et dès octobre 2020 un budget de 156
millions d'euros a permis de développer
89 centre de santé spécialisés dans ce
syndrome comprenant des équipes
pluridisciplinaires
elles sont accessibles sur prescription
médicale
le ministre de la santé britannique a
également alloué un budget de plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros à des
études menées sur le co vie de long en
france la prise en charge dans n'est
pour le moment qu'à ses balbutiements
le gouvernement à accorder une
reconnaissance automatique en maladie
professionnelle aux soignants malades
ducobu qui présente des séquelles
respiratoire mais rien d'autre pour le
moment le 17 février 2021 l'assemblée
nationale a adopté une résolution visant
à créer un dispositif d'indemnisation
pour les copies de lyon mais l'unité qui
leur est dédié à l'hôpital foch de
suresnes
les réacs qu'ovide est visité par
emmanuel macron fait figure d'exception
l'écho vie de long sont plutôt condamné
à errer de médecin en médecin sans
toujours trouvé de soulagement je ne
peux pas vous dire s'il ya un retard en
france ou pas je ne suis pas expert du
sujet au fur et à mesure effectivement
on a découvert cette entité qui est là
qu vite long il existe déjà dans la
majorité des gros hôpitaux des
consultations spécialisées
il y a donc des centres postaux dédié je
ne suis pas certain qu'ils sont au
nombre de ceux qui existent au royaume
uni malgré tout ce sont plutôt
heureusement des symptômes qui ont
tendance à régresser avec le temps fin
avril
l'elysée a communiqué sur l'éco vie de
long expliquant qu'il ne serait pas les
invisibles et les oubliés de la maladie
mais pour le moment ils sont seuls pour
affronter leur douleur à quand une prise
en charge plus adapté